eh bien bon soir vladimir kramnik est le
quatorzième champion du monde d'échecs
bonsoir et loi bonsoir stéphane bonsoir
à tous événement exceptionnel
aujourd'hui vladimir kramnik a tenu
facilement a été noire et devient donc
le 14e champion du monde d'échecs de la
lignée de stanis mais quel parti quand
même parce que quelle tension il y avait
entre les joueurs et on a vu qu rami qui
s'est libéré à la fin puisqu'il a levé
les bras au ciel ça c'est rare aux
échecs de voir un joueur comme ça
exprimé sa joie après une partie on peut
dire que il a fait un gros gros coup on
peut dire chronique chronique était
extrêmement heureux extrêmement content
on le sentait ému dans cette fin de
partie c'était superbe
et effectivement aujourd'hui la tenue
assez facilement avec les noirs grosse
partie quand même mais à noter comme
stéphane les joueurs n'en pouvais plus
les deux étaient extrêmement fatigué
dans cette fin de match exactement tout
à fait la formule du match était donc de
16 parties c'est très court notamment
deux parties le week-end à chaque fois
donc à partie par semaine de voir deux
parties le week-end c'est évidemment un
match très difficile à jouer c'est parti
comme ça aussi forte aussi intense on a
bien vu comment donner que ce tarif
était très fatigué il est quand même
bien revenu kasparov physiquement dans
cette dernière semaine il a posé
d'énormes problèmes chroniques en
impression qu'il avait réussi enfin le
viser à la le cibler le cramique il a
bien tenu
vladimir malgré quelques tensions il
aurait pu perdre la partie de mardi
mais finalement la déesse du vieux
déchets qu'allissa était avec lui
effectivement qu allissa avec vladimir
kramnik à la conférence de presse c'est
bien
il ya eu beaucoup de questions pour
ramener quand même exceptionnellement
elle était bien cette conférence de
presse et notamment le doute plane
encore sur la suite des événements
puisque kasparov a dit qu'il était
engagé avec good guys
il ne peut donc plus quitter man games
et il va jouer les matches de
qualification et prochaine donc tu as
part of dans un nouveau rôle le rôle du
challenger et chroniques attendra donc
le centre challenger à lui festival on
va voir ça évidemment ça c'est la suite
des événements mais post on va encore
savoureux sotelma qui a encore beaucoup
de choses à voir beaucoup de choses à
faire on aura peut-être avant
l'interview de trani commente être avoir
d'autres interviews on avait joué
lautier et qui était son monde en
kramnik tout à l'heure qui est venu nous
voir vers la fin du match et l'or mais
on va quand même analyser cette partie
peut-être d'abord stephen on va regarder
quelques images quelques images de la
partie voilà ça c'est si la fin de la
partie alors c'est la fin d'un règne
comme les moments à ne pas oublier ça
fait 15 ans qu'il est champion du monde
garry kasparov et là en direct tout à
l'heure quelqu'un auquel ils ont fini
par proposer nul travnik trop solide il
parle d'après joël lautier chronique est
un monstre en défense et il l'a prouvé
puisqu'il a défendu avec un sang-froid
un excellent admirable se produire
kasparov ne bouge plus il comprend voilà
la propose nul est donc terminée voilà à
lannion qui lève les bras un rat qui
lève les bras au ciel ou les bras au
ciel qui se libèrent chronique est
heureux il est heureux à quel
soulagement
on peut imaginer pas d' analyse l'a1 ils
ont réussi dans cette partie ouais
simplement que c'est la fin de garry
kasparov et finale en cause car enfin
assez assez beau perdant on peut dire on
est craint le cantique très très belle
chronique super héros y avait évidemment
une standing-ovation à ce moment là le
public était fou le public était debout
alors on a vu aussi la différence pour
moi j'ai vu un peu liquide kasparov qui
faisait triste mine
tous les gens qui l'entouraient pendant
ce match et puis évidemment linverse les
gens qui entourent et kramnik pas très
nombreux en fait puisqu'on a peu vu
beaucoup de monde mais avant de vue que
joël lautier où j'en avais des jouets le
discours voilà pour une interview de nos
confrères de canal plus
ac serait un jour il joël très
tranquille très très satisfait c'est
vrai que c'était un très long combat
pour lui aussi est donc exténué
complètement et là il nous a quittés
pour les faire la fête évidemment avec
l'équipe clanique donc joël illes casse
et bas relief les trois entraîneurs qui
sont venus ici il y en a eu d'autres
avant notamment sac et f
mais là donc évidemment dans le conte
chronique c'est la fête en famille ce
soir exactement alors ça y est on va
venir à cette partie
on va on voit là on va là commenté
kasparov
pour la première fois des vies il n'a
pas joué des quatre de tout le match et
là mais il tente le coup il tente le
coup effectivement de toute façon sur
quatre il avait rien sur ces quatre non
plus carrick kasparov était à bout de
souffle n'ai plus rien à jouer il a joué
des quatre et on a enfin vu ce que
chronique avait prévu qu'elle a fait 6
c4 sur ces 4 hier au cices donc l'ouest
n'diaye valais le niveau pardon
l'animent zoo sur les c3 évidemment
qu'ils étaient 3 c ce coup on le sait
kramnik aurait probablement mais il faut
en d4 hautement probable en tout cas
kasparov ne lui a pas permis de clouer
le cavalier il a joué trois donc déviant
vers une catalane
ouais tout à fait alors en fait
probablement que kasparov essayer de
bonnes ouvertures dont il connaît bien
évidemment mais probablement ils
n'essaient pas de trouver nouveautés
théorique ou de placer une nouveauté
théorique il essaie simplement de mettre
un maximum d'attention sur cette partie
est de voir si chronique dans une
position entre guillemets normal
arrive à tenir le choc sur les nerfs et
effectivement qu'espace dans cette
partie ne tentera pas de forcer les
événements il va jouer tranquille il va
jouer une position paisible et calme en
attendant un peu de dire enfin aux dix
ans akram dit bah voilà il faut que tu
fasses nul mais d'abord il faut que tu
joues il ya rien y'a rien à faire mais
joue d'abord et on fera nul après voilà
on va voir si tu craques et on va voir -
et d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'on va voir
dans cette partie il a fait des cinq de
classe a été joué très très vite
évidemment les joueurs sont très chauds
kasparov a dépensé 2 minutes pour les 10
premiers coups à noter que le joueur ont
déjà joué souvent cette ouverture entre
entre eux entrent dans les grands
tournois qui joue d'habitude mois la
catalane c'est quand même une ouverture
très connu et 3 petit rock les dogues
n'oublie pas de rock est évidemment donc
en fait les noirs jouent ici une sorte
de gambie dame
sauf que les blancs au lieu de sortir le
phocéen ils ont sorti le fou j'ai 2
c'est un choix mais la formation du
candidat mais évidemment pour le noir
c'est considéré comme très solide c'est
celle que vous voyez ici le fou le
cavalier de rock rapide et le pion des
cinq petit rock qui manquent et la trame
unique joue dépensé 4 donne le centre
mais pour reprendre ce pion et bien
kasparov doit perdre du temps puisqu'il
devrait le récupérer avec la dame ou
bien on le sait stéphane il faut pas
sortir la dame en début de partie
faut pas sortir gagnent trop tôt m comme
ces deux à six dames francesca kasparov
récupère son pion voilà hélas les noirs
en profite pour jouer b5 kathak la dame
et une fois que la dame a bougé en c2 et
bien hop ils peuvent mettre leurs
fiançailles et juste à temps puisque les
blancs menacé de sortir leurs cavaliers
et de mettre en jeu leur fougue et 2
voilà sortir le cavalier pour attaquer
la torah 8
maintenant évidemment ça perd en
efficacité puisque les fous viendrait
changer est évidemment vu la situation
dans le match et bien kramnik desquelles
un échange à faire a priori si ce n'est
pas mauvais il va le faire
il va le faire se rapproche de la partie
nul donc de la victoire du match fou
bessette et ici on attendait donc être
assez logiquement un coup comme kbc 3 ou
alors à coup comme fief 4 millions les
coûts classique dans cette position et
n'ont qu'un mini-jeu fou des deux un
plasma rohff kasparov vous voulez donner
un petit coup genre l'asie joue ouais
voilà un petit coup qui peut menacer
certaines choses mais ouais qui passe
qui est pas très dangereux mais qui
diacre amicaux joués les conserveries
cette position est déjà eu lieu entre
les deux joueurs est en tout cas en
kramnik va jouer un thème qu'on a déjà
vues entre les deux joueurs c'est à dire
qui va harceler la dame il va harceler
alan enfin ça durera pas très longtemps
il vous faut et 4 et la kasparov
la dame attaquer le problème c'est que
cette dame du compte comme on a joué fou
d2d cette dame n'a pas trop de cases à
sa disposition deux cases intéressante
c'est à dire notamment par exemple si la
dame géant b3 et bien le fou qui est un
dessin en quatre vallées ont des cinq
attaquants la dame nouvelle fois revenue
je vais continuer à attaquer la lame et
ça c'est une position que le joueur on
va déjà jouer nous semble à linares
alors c'est possible stéphane s'est pas
complètement sûr mais ça c'est en tout
cas ce qui est sûr c'est que si c'était
là bas c'était les couleurs inversées
oui c'est à dire chronique les blancs
caisse complètement tout à fait caisse
port autonome cena ici même s'ils n'ont
donc évitant que le foot continue à
harceler la dame mais la dame il passe
super bien placé en scène s'éclaire
la dame est de placer en scène est
d'ailleurs chronique le prouvent puisque
dans cette position il joue un coup
assez inattendus comme stéphane dijoux
le couffo bessette way genre et ben
voila moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est de
repousser états d'âme je perde autant
mais c'est pas grave
à toi de jouer si tu rejoues la dame
évidemment je te rejetera tacle adam je
propose nul oui et si tu joues à autre
chose et b en fait t'as pas de bons
coups voilà tout à fait état d'âme est
mal placée tout simplement garry
kasparov
notez que pour les noirs ce qui est très
important dans cette position c'est de
bien verrouiller la case e 4 1 petit
point ce temps est contrôlé par le
cabinet sis et par le fou bessette et
les blancs peuvent jamais joué le coup
de 2,4 envahir le centre avec leurs
pions oui doit effectivement comme on a
dit au début les blancs les noirs ont
donné le centre donc les blancs ont deux
pions au centre cc dollar contre 1 seule
l'option noir en v6 donc les blancs
évidemment veulent avancer leurs pions
sans trop en plus il ya une petite
faiblesse pour le nord stéphane qui est
très important c'est l'option arriérés
ans et c'est tout à fait on dit qu'il
érigerait pourquoi il vient parce que la
casse ces cinq il ya plus de pions qui
peuvent la défendre donc si les blancs
venaient à verrouiller cette case avec
des pièces cependant je serai tout le
temps en arrière et pourrait pas être
protégé par un de ses homologues une
spécialité d'un anatoli karpov donc ici
l'enjeu des noirs et bien c'est
d'empêcher le 4 et de jouer ces 5 et à
ce moment là ils auront égaliser
complètement la position tout à fait
mais cette chronique est revenu sous f
4k soir là une menace donc me rajoute 2
pour une deuxième fois le fou oui après
avoir joué deux trois fois la dame déjà
ils rejouent le fougueux attaquant le
pion ses sept puisque la dame et le fou
attaque
cette petite faiblesse noir une work
cramique chronique sans risque pas grand
chose il vaut le coup des six qui contre
attaque le fou tout ça tout simplement
fou des six c'est pas mal et qui est des
cinq qui étaient un peu moins fort
stefan füle et 6 c très bien ça mais les
pièces pour les échanger en fait
tranquillement
qui est bd 2k sports où je joue pas mal
parce que bon il avait le choix dans les
développements de son cavalier
si on revient à la position en principe
la case où on a envie d'aller c'est la
case c3 mais là elle s'avère
complètement inefficace sept cavaliers
en c3 et bloquer tout seul il peut aller
nulle part complet nulle part il
n'empêche la dame de contrôler la
violence et ils bouchent la colonne
c'est voilà donc deux inconvénients
alors que lecavalier
quand il vient en d2 c'est beaucoup
mieux on voit qu'ils bougent pas la
colonne ces voix là ils menacent
probablement ce cavalier de venir sur la
case b3 pour contrôler cette fameuse
casse c5 et éventuellement aller en a
cinq voilà aussi petit ennui ça permet
au noir éventuellement de prendre le fou
f4 et de disloquer un peu les pions du
roi blanc
alors on a été surpris par le coup de
crâne nikki si stéphane on s'attendait à
ce que vladimir je vous fous prend fou
oui puisque c'est un échange a priori
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour chroniques
et après l'appui on prendra jouer le
ku'damm des six ici attaquant le pion
forçant les blancs a joué le coup eux 2
3 e 2 3 ou un autre coup quitte des
fonctions à vous qui venez par exemple
est maintenant jouer de toute façon
qu'est b17 l'idc c5 ou alors tour s'est
vite suivi de ces 5 s'avère tranquille
d'autant plus que le poste là d'amendés
6 est très solide
oui là les rues a dit à l'ats qu'il
allait radial ce poste pour la dame elle
est active et pas attaquable donc on
était assez surpris puisque kramnik à
jouer parce que dans cette position
directement qui a et b 17
donc ne permettant plus à la dame de
passer sur la casse des six ça ça va
être un peu surprenant et après
cavaliers b3 on a vu qu ramené de
commencer à réfléchir et là on s'est dit
ça y est chronique joue petit bras
oui il arrive pas à forcer des
événements il invite à prendre de
décision dans cette partie et kasparov
avec sa stratégie de ne rien faire va
réussir à le rendre fou oui peut-être
mais c'était ma mère n'a eu peur un peu
de ça mais la chronique ne s'emballe pas
tranquillement ils ont plein de la
position de son fou c'est la troisième
fois que je vous se fout quand même oui
et maintenant se souvient sur la case
des 5 et bizarrement élevé au centre se
fout en fait est parfaitement placé
puisqu'il n'est pas attaquable jamais
les blancs ne peuvent jouer e24 pour le
chasser fait clair et se fout finalement
pêche le pion blanc aussi d'avancer
contrôle des jolies casse notamment la
castille 4 et le cavalier b3 ou 6 km
prises le couffo dessins que c'est un
coup simplement qui fait que le foot
n'est plus en prison 17 dont il ya plus
de thèmes ya plus d'un hectare et le
soin est fou des 5 c'est un joli coup en
fait je crois que chronique qui s'est
dit choqué food et 5e il a l'air bien
placé et voilà tout avait quelque chose
dans ce style la tour d un kasparov
sediba matour chelem est là elle a l'air
bien placé aussi et on voit quand même
que la tour en rayons x
elle touche toutes les pièces noires qui
sont sur la colonne des c'est à dire pas
mal
donc si les noirs sont tentés tout et
c'est simple ou 1,5 et bien là après la
prise évidemment la tour d un se
retrouvent super bien voilà ce réveil
elle peut attaquer beaucoup de pièces
chronique se démonte pas joue dams est
pas mal puisque l'idée encore pour les
noirs c'est de contrôler la casse ces 5
et en plus cette dame est bien placé à
1,7 n'est toujours pas attaquable et
maintenant les tours sont liés et là on
ne voyait plus de coûts pour kasparov
stéphane on se dit qu'est ce qu'il va
faire on essaie d'améliorer toutes ces
pièces on n'a pas trouvé du tout quoi
faire et finalement kasparov donc se
résigne dans cette position devant
l'absence générale de coûts à échanger
des pièces en jean qui vit aux 5 quelle
est celle qui propose des changes des
fous de cases blanches et ça c'est bien
pour kramnik ad'ailleurs krainik
évidemment s'est jeté dessus d'autant
plus ça fait but louable en fout projet
de rapprocher d'eux c'est très important
effectivement kramnik perd le contrôle
de la casse et 6 mai il a fait bien peu
la pression du roi blanc et maintenant
ils jouent caïds et 5 très vite plutôt
bien joué attaquant le fou et 4 voilà il
a décidé vladimir kramnik d'échangés
encore une pièce pas bête il faut
échanger quelques pièces alors lancé six
petites passes tactique on va voir tunis
24 la dame mais kramnik fait d'abord le
coup alors on attendait que la dame
bouge n'importe où ce qui avait pas
l'air terrible ce qui donnait des
possibilités avec as part of il a choqué
point fkt cheikh - est un coup
intermédiaires et l'apprendre la dame et
à un coût de kasparov un tout petit peu
inattendu on va dire on pouvait
s'attendre à la reprise du pion mais
quand même qui parle kappa le rebond
puisque ça affaiblit le roi blanc
il ya des matches quatre ans castro se
démonte pas il fait quand même
d'apprendre à me prend cavaliers puisque
même si la dame étant prises si les
noirs prennent la dame lagarde est une
faute
ça serait une fois puisque les bleus ont
d'abord prennent la dame avec échec
le roi est obligé de bouger et ensuite
on prend le fou et ça gagne une pièce
d'une pièce puisque le cavalier n'aura
aucune peine à ressortir c'est important
vérifiez toujours que le caviar ou
sortent mais là il arrive en c6 après
yahoo il veut
bref il y avait une petite place
tactique kasparov mais saddam emprise
mécanique ne peut pas la prendre
donc kramnik enlève sa dame tout
simplement joue dames 8
et cette fois ci des attaques
sérieusement la dame de kasparov qui
doit bouger et là on sentait vraiment
stéphane que c'était égal ce qu'on ne
voyait plus comment se prémunir contre
le cou aux 6,5 pour kasparov ou alors
contre l'autre possibilité est
changeante le coup kébé vite urgences et
les escaliers oui tout à fait bref quel
sport joue dame f3 à noter qu'on va voir
que dans cette partie là demain 8 aussi
va sortir de cette quasi revenir on a vu
beaucoup de comme ça d'un coup de
balancier de pièces il ya un peu
d'intimidation dans cette partie puisque
casque rein minka d'abord joué son
foulard jouer kasparov a aussi joué
saddam sur des cases un peu bizarre et
on va voir qu'il va y avoir comme ça
beaucoup de coups alors la chronique
joue le coup libérateur voilà il la
caisse pas empêché qui avaient vite à
cause de cavic cet échec
oui et la tour serait comprise donc ici
le coup libérateur c'est ça c'est aussi
ce 5ème 6e 500 relève le coup le pion
blanc au centre et on va voir ça échange
encore des pièces va sa menace au 5e 4
stéphane ça c'est très fort on écoute le
15 mars ne peut pas tolérer
très logiquement donc pour ouvrir la
colonne de sa tour
il prend en ce sens qu une champions
prendre 5 et après cavalli prensa
échange des cavaliers jorge jesus
on est obligé d'échanger des cavaliers
dame prend et là on s'est dit ça y est
c'est nul ouais ça y est c'est nul et on
va voir que kaspar on va quand même
essayer de continuer à provoquer kramnik
en fait il va essayer d'amener à
cramique faire des erreurs
en tout simplement en essayant de garder
l'équilibré au maximum et ne pas
échanger de pièces tout à fait donc là
kasparov
maintenant on va faire une stratégie je
ne fais rien mais toi non plus donc on
joue on ne fait pas nul on joue
exceptionnellement tour d2 la chronique
a super bien joué en amical à vraiment
jouer un coup grand style normalement
alors n'importe quel grand maître
normale entre guillemets aurait joué
soit tour vite soit tour des huit breaks
pour mettre les tours au centre tout à
fait soit éventuellement un coup de
fouet mais crown et qui lui a trouvé ça
super beaucoup tour à 8
a priori on n'arrive pas à le comprendre
ce couple - il ya une tour en fuite mais
en fait les annales et 5000 autres tours
en 1 8
la torah 8 était en prise de la dame a
qualifié de chronique mais d'un autre
côté la tour habite défendez le pion
assisté vrai aussi donc on s'est dit bon
retour 1,8 joli coup peut-être qu'il a
envie de juillet 2004 chronique -
changer les dames mais en fait pas du
tout kasparov 12,3 et là on comprend
l'idée chronique quand il joue
retour aussi ce tour si c'est pas mal
parce que c'est tout va pouvoir
coulisser vers le roi blanc
6 voir maintenant à six attaquants
pouvoir attaquer laurent blanc est en
même temps aussi elle protège à la une
petite feuille cette tour sur le pion à
six qui peut être faible du côté noir
mais là avec cette tour sur la sixième
il n'y a pas de problème pas de problème
donc toi aussi tu auras d1 kasparov sais
pas trop quoi faire dans cette position
ça paraît clair tram il attend de voir
ce que va faire kramnik ont fait attaque
la dame 3-6 3-6 atacama il faut que la
dame bougies elle a pas beaucoup de cas
cette dame
la dame est venue en d5 là on
s'attendait à ce que cramique échange
les dames on s'est dit c'est logique il
va échanger les dames mais non en fait
non c'est là que se révèle en fait toute
la force de plantes chronique c'est que
il a passé sa tour en f6 c'est pas pour
échanger les dames c'est pour attaquer
droite kasparov et qui dit attaque sur
le roi dit on garde les dames en garde
les dames exactement et pourquoi bien
cramé que lui à son roi hyper bien
renforcés et toutes les pièces autour
kasparov ya des trous on voit des trous
possible soit par la soie par là bref le
rot weiss parfait patron sécurité donc
rémi garde les dames joda me 8 petit
coup un peu alternatif un peu surprenant
quand on sait que chronique doit faire
nul tranquille à se demander s'il aurait
les nerfs mais il a les nerfs chronique
là en fait ils jouent pas pour faire
annuler cette position il joue pour
jouer les meilleurs coups tout
simplement d'amener vite on savait plus
et la parole mais en fait attend quelque
part c'est horrible safadi la jda or
c'est un ouais bon ben ça change de
colonne pas mal pas mal mais moi par
contre j'ai un plan lui dit kramnik joue
g6 alors on se demande ce que ça veut
dire secoué en donnant leur dire mais en
fait il veut pouvoir jouer peut-être le
coup tours f5 et en plus il semblerait
que la structure des pions noirs soient
mieux sur cases blanches de la couleur
opposée celle du fou oui c'est aussi un
ça peut avoir des motifs d'attac sur le
roi blanc aussi éventuellement joue h 5
h quatre peut-être ça mais doit attaquer
laurent blanc ça c'est là ça c'est
l'idée principale en fait de geci c'est
de jouer à 5 h 4 et c'est bien vu en
fait cramique comme on le sait c'est un
spécialiste de l'anticipation du plan de
l'adversaire avec geci s'il fait ça
parfaitement puisque kasparov n'a rien à
faire donc ne fait rien pour ces deux
chroniques joue h5
maintenant on comprend bien le truc la
tour qui est en 28 ans ferme et elle va
passer
cicas par vengeance est en jeu suite au
rachat suite et j'ai quatre attaquants
le roi
avec mes attaquants kasparov dit stop là
oui bon ok j'ai un fait un peu n'importe
quoi
ouais tu me chauffe j'arrête tout
j'arrête les frais je remplace mon
cavalier avec des 2 et des deux il veut
revenir en catastrophe avec le cavalier
fourchette attaque en attaque le fou la
foule et la tour voilà tout à fait donc
ramené dit stop to have 5
oui stop stop donc l' attaquent la dame
attaque adam k sport revient aux 4
propose les chanteuses ah oui parce
qu'il comprend bien que c'est grammy qui
peut avoir de l'attaqué alors il faut
changer les dames pour essayer de
continuer la partie et la chronique elle
joue les bons coups là c'est là je crois
qu'il a joué le coup qui égalise
vraiment la position le coup libérateur
le vrai c'est espions c7 détériorée
depuis le début de partie
tout à fait eh bien il le met ans et 5
maintenant il n'a pas peur des fantômes
vladimir kramnik l'idée c'est évidemment
jouer ces cinq c4 après quoi y'a plus
qu'à tenir le pion à 6 et on tiendra
toute la chaîne d'options dont des pions
s'échangent et ça c'est bon pour
cramique ici il a la meilleure structure
possible bref si cramique jousset 5 6 4
c'est terminé kasparov pourra plus
gagner
kasparov donc prend sa chance maintenant
c'est son dernier moment il je t'aime
prends dam tour prend tout reprend et 4
et donc c'est dit ouh là où la salle art
show puisque les pions de kasparov en
l'air de 1 d'envahir le centre va jouer
f 4 5 et paix qui règne au caire voilà
et ça à l'air chaud
quel vieux 4 a très bien placé donc on
se dit ouh là stop
attention krainik il faut faire
attention toutefois ce sens car il a
joué près si oui aux commentaires à ce
moment là y'avait joël lautier en direct
qui avait l'air de dire que chrome
nickel et tenir oui et quévert de dire
que ça laisse à venir bon on va voir
pourquoi f4 parce qu'en fait après tours
6 faut quelqu'un quasiment forcé
kasparov doit jouer le coup suivant ou
5e cinq attaques le fou alors là faut
pas se tromper il faut aller en sept
mois la fois la hausse est parce qu il
faut même si angolaise et détours doublé
voilà il faut que les noirs jouent le
coup à vii f6 mais en plus il faut
contrôler les kadhafistes voilà nos
packs le quai louis-blanc iai et pour
pas que le cavalier blanc saute sur
cette case en faisant des échecs
meurtrier alors je vais de lotir
remarque évidemment que son cavalier 4
directement mes chroniques je vois ces
cinq c4 et c'était bouclé cette termine
ses boucles et pourquoi pas ce qui a plu
d'affaiblissement pions dont kasparov la
tente sa chance une fois depuis six
jours b3 il veut bloquer l'occurrence et
5 pour pouvoir l'attaquer avec le
cavalier calais ou 4 et hop je te mange
ton pions kramnik exactement mais
kramnik raji le premier il attaque lui
même la chaîne de pions blanche qui
menace de gagner un pion en jouant f6
menace pions prend 1,5
oui qu'est-ce qu'on fait obligés de
jouer cavalier 3 oui pour protéger les
lions durant
pion stéphane quand même bref j'ai aussi
pu prendre le pire mais là il y avait le
coup je vois le tiens mais parler du
coût
un brillant jeu sera dur il faut prendre
si c'est évidemment faux problème 6
puisque ce retour français 5 voilà
surtout il ya toujours deux échecs qui
gagnent le cavalier attaque le roi et le
cavalier exactement qui hérita fait
simplement et là on se demande ce que
peut faire kasparov dans cette position
ouais parce que tombe la tour noire
menace de s'infiltrer dans le camp blanc
et bien après qui veut dire 3 stéphane
c'est très simple en échange de 2 alors
on échange des tours bref position
extrêmement simple à tenir pour les nids
mercredi qu' aucun doute qu'il n'y
arrivera donc kasparov après si c'est
bien l'objet joaquin diaz 3 et là on
sent quand comme quand kramnik commencé
à échanger les pions que ça va être
tranquille
ouais ils jouent peut surprendre c'est
un acte très vite cavaliers prend
attention quand même aux menaces la
menace ses cahiers des 3 ou qu'elle ait
17 mai exactement qui agrège l'audience
et 5 effectivement c'est pour ça que
cramique joue le coup tour des huit très
bien joué active la tour et empêche le
cavalier de venir attaquer le pion c5
crée une menace en plus des fans
puisqu'il veut jouer j'ai site g5 et
changer encore des pions exactement et
commencer à faiblir toujours le
rappelant qu'à spa rouge ou h4 est là le
dernier coup de ce match effectué tour
des 5 le plan le plan de chronique c'est
fou des six way qui va chasser le
cavalier et puis et puis nul puis
tranquille nul aurait forcé et puis je
peux rien faire il a plus assez
d'arguments
voilà le dernier coup de ce match tour
des cinq kasparov propose nul et crame
nick wey les bras en l'air world
championnes et champions du monde
14e champion du monde alors à noter que
kasparov a dit qu'il allait jouer
si tout se passe bien mais le prochain
cycle de champion du monde il allait
quand même essayer de revenir et de se
qualifier pour jouer contre kramnik
qu'il considère il a bien dit comme
effectivement le 14e champion du monde
d'échecs
je crois que tout le monde à le
considérer ainsi
reste à cramique quand même à confirmer
notamment dans les tournois
effectivement pour l'instant il est 14e
champion du monde parce qu'il a battu
kasparov
mais pour l'instant il a battu ni shirov
ni hollande il a battu aucun des autres
joueurs et en tout cas le match contre
un ennemi il a jamais eu lieu le match
kramnik à nantes n'a jamais eu lieu
effectivement ça serait quand même
intéressant de voir ce que ça peut
donner parce qu'on peut très bien
assister à une situation stéphane où il
ya trois joueurs qui dominent des échecs
winnik attendait chaque instant l'autre
à cause du style ça peut arriver voilà
et disons qu'à semer rohff et chacun
battant l'autre nom qu'on aurait comment
dire lequel est le plus fort oui très
difficile ça serait ça serait possible
mais bon c'est pas ça pas encore été le
cas
en tout cas pour l'instant chronique et
le sol est oui oui à avoir battu
kasparov depuis que kasparov aînés en
match un match s'était jamais arrivé
avant donc là on va donc assister à une
belle année je pense parce que le
nouveau champion du monde ça va
forcément générer de nouvelles de
nouvelles choses de nouveaux combats de
nouveau stéphane on peut comparer ça à
la dissolution de l'assemblée nationale
ouais ouais si on la faisait vraiment le
direct ça veut dire qu'on ne sait pas du
tout ce qui va se passer
oui ce que ça va être bien pas bien ce
que c'est la gaffe du siècle qu'est ce
que cramique champion du monde ça va
être bien ou pas bien on va voir a
priori ça va être bien parce que on ne
soyons positifs un petit jeune qui
arrive c'est toujours sympa ouais donc
voilà c'est une dissolution
rajeunissantes exactement donc on en
saura plus pour la suite alors à noter
quand même que samedi théoriquement
ridoré avoir au moins une partie
éventuellement des parties rapides
oui alors c'est à dire qu'en fait le
problème de brock james dans le contrat
les joueurs doivent jouer jusqu'au bout
ouais mais liam et la casse parfait cram
dit que ceux connaissant assez bien et
le match pour eux est terminée oui donc
ils vont arriver
poum poum nul voila ils vont proposer de
faire des parties nulles ou du blitz
voilà bah vous proposer pour nous de
faire des parties rapides
maintenant est-ce que travail de
l'accepter c'est pas sûr parce que
maintenant qu'ils championne du monde
s'y perd ce mini match bon ben c'est pas
très bien oui tout est donc que bon donc
valoir qu on verra on verra bien samedi
en tout cas on vous donne rendez vous à
16h stefan wey pour en tout cas une
animation échec
on ne sait pas si ça sera une partie
donc jouer une partie longue dont jouer
des parties semi-rapides jouer bref on
vous donne rendez-vous 16h mais en tout
cas on félicite krainik 14e champion du
monde d'échecs c'est l'actualité
de cette fin de match et c'était
vraiment un superbe match voilà donc
rendez-vous à samedi et puis pour le
reste de l'année pour la suite diagonale
parce qu'il valeur beaucoup d'événements
à suivre notamment des parties rapides
très intéressantes notamment dans les
grands prix diagonale et puis tout le
tournoi qu'on va couvrir ne serait-ce
que le tournoi de hollande mais quand tu
es en janvier le temps linares etc
actualité chargée donc toute façon les
émissions régulières de diagonale c'est
vendredi soir et c'est toute l'année à
toute heure 24 heures sur 24 en différé
bref on vous donne rendez-vous bientôt
et merci de nous avoir suivis ciao